IMPEACHMENT A LYNCHING.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT."
♪ ♪
GOOD EVENING, I AM BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE U.S.
WILL LET SOMEBODY ELSE FIGHT
OVER "THE LONG BLOODSTAINED SAND
IN THE MIDDLE EAST."
ANNOUNCING A PERMANENT
CEASE-FIRE BETWEEN TURKEY AND
SYRIAN-BASED KURDS.
THE PRESIDENT LAUDING THE EFFORT
AS A RELEASE WITHOUT SPILLING
ONE DROP OF AMERICAN BLOOD.
THE RESPONSE ON CAPITOL HILL,
THE FOREIGN POLICY MOVE DO NOT
AGREE THAT THIS IS A MAJOR
BREAKTHROUGH.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS JOINING US ON THE
NORTH ONE.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS CAUTIOUS
TODAY SAYING THAT IT IS TOO
EARLY FOR CONGRATULATIONS.
ADDING THAT THE DEFINITION OF
PERMANENT IN THAT PART OF THE
WORLD IS QUESTIONABLE.
BUT FOR THE MOMENT, AT LEAST, HE
WAS ONLY TOO HAPPY TO BE TAKING
THE APPARENT WIN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLARED
VICTORY FOR HIS FOREIGN POLICY
TODAY ANNOUNCING THAT TURKEY HAD
AGREED TO MAKE THE FIVE DAY LAW
AND CEASE-FIRE OF KURDISH FORCES
IN SYRIA PERMANENT.
>> I GREET YOU THIS MORNING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TO ANNOUNCE A
MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH IN ACHIEVING
A BETTER FUTURE FOR SYRIA AND
FOR THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP LIFTED
SANCTIONS HE IMPOSED ON TURKEY
BUT ADDED A PERMANENT SOLUTION
TO THE TURKISH-CURD CONFLICT
WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE WITHOUT
THE FIGHTING THAT ERUPTED DURING
THE INVASION.
TO SPEAK OF THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING OF THE THREE DAY FIGHT
WAS DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR
ABILITY TO MAKE AN AGREEMENT
WITH TURKEY AND THE KURDS THAT
COULD NEVER HAVE BEEN MADE
WITHOUT THEIR SHORT-TERM
OUTBURSTS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LEAVING IT
TO TURKEY AND RUSSIA TO CONTROL
THE 20-MILE STEVE STONE
ESTABLISHED IN THE AGREEMENT.
SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM PRAYS TO
THE CEASE-FIRE, BUT WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT COMES NEXT.
>> I AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT
WITHOUT SANCTIONS THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN NO CEASE-FIRE, BUT YOU
CANNOT RELY ON SYRIA, RUSSIA, OR
TURKEY TO PROTECT THE
UNITED STATES AGAINST ISIS.
SPEAK OF PRESIDENT APPEARED TO
GET BY FROM THE KURDS, THE
ENFORCER TWEETING "WE THANK
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR HIS TIRELESS
LEFT FOR THE NEXT EFFORT
STOPPING THE TURKISH ATTACK AND
JIHADIST GROUPS ON OUR PEOPLE."
BUT DEMOCRATS HAMMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CHUCK SCHUMER WORRIED ABOUT A
POSSIBLE RESURGENCE OF ISIS.
>> IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS UNDONE OVER
FIVE YEARS OF PROGRESS AGAINST
THE ISLAMIC STATE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP PLAGUING DOWN
ISIS MEMBERS WHO ESCAPED
CAPTIVITY DURING THE FIGHTING.
>> THERE WERE A FEW THAT GOT
OUT.
A SMALL NUMBER, RELATIVELY
SPEAKING.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN LARGELY
RECAPTURED PARIS >> THE
PRESIDENT ALSO CONFIRMED A SMALL
CONTINGENT OF U.S. FORCES WOULD
REMAIN IN EASTER SYRIA TO
PROTECT THE OIL FIELDS.
PROTECTING
TAOTECTING
TALKECTING
TALKINTING
TALKINGING
TALKING AG
TALKING ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS,
WHO TWEETED THE LAST TIME I
CHECKED CONVERSE NEVER APPROVED
FORCES TO SERIOUS ECONOMIC
FORCES.
PUTTING FORCES IN HARM'S WAY IS
ILLEGAL AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SPECIAL
ENVOY TO SYRIA JIM JEFFREY WAS
UNCLEAR TODAY ABOUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO WITH
THE OIL FIELDS?
THAT IS A REALLY GOOD QUESTION,
AND WE ARE WORKING HARD.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN ANSWER AT THIS
TIME.
>> JEFFREY TOLD THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE THAT THE UNITED STATES
HAS NO IDEA WHERE ABOUT 100 ISIS
FIGHTERS WHO ESCAPED CUSTODY
CURRENTLY ARE.
JEFFREY APPEARED TO CONTRADICT
THE PRESIDENT'S CLAIMS OF
VICTORY WHEN HE LIKENED THE
TURKISH INCURSION TO TRAGEDY.
THAT IT HAD BEEN THE FELLOW U.S.